in Kabul smoke and anger filled the
streets the Taliban launched an attack
against what's known as the green
village a secure compound for foreigners
on Monday night by Tuesday morning
residents were on the streets angry that
their neighborhood has been repeatedly
targeted and blamed the international
presence security forces attempted to
disperse protesters with gunfire my
friends and relatives were killed and
wounded in the blast this is the fifth
time this area has been attacked we want
officials to move the furnace away from
this area the Taliban detonated a
tractor packed with explosives a search
and rescue operation for foreigners and
residents lasted through the night more
than a dozen residents were killed it
was a big explosion that collapsed the
ceiling of my house and shattered my
windows my nephew was killed the blasts
came during the final minutes of a
national interview with Selma Halil said
the u.s. chief negotiator in talks with
the Taliban
he arrived in Kabul on Sunday to reveal
a draft peace deal to Afghan leaders
halil's ad revealed that 5,400 US troops
will withdraw in the first four and a
half months after a deal is signed
leaving 8600 troops to withdraw in
future waves in return the Taliban must
enter into talks with the Afghan
government and contain armed groups like
Al Qaeda and ISIL let me claim that what
is who as I cannot tell you which bases
we will leave because of security
concerns but we will share it after the
agreement is signed we've not even
shared that information with the Taliban
yet but we will withdraw our troops from
five bases in the first 135 days if
everything goes as planned
despite alleles adds optimism the
Taliban is still looking for leverage
fighters launched a major operation in
Kunduz over the weekend attempting a
repeat of a 2015 takeover of the city
when US and Afghan Special Forces
repelled the attack they moved south
attacking Pali Kumari another provincial
capital leading to questions about when
their violence will decrease yad sneeze
the ceasefire issue will be discussed in
talks directly between the Taliban and
Afghan government and that is part of
our deal with the Taliban the Taliban
will gradually decrease fighting which
will lead to a ceasefire something that
for Afghans can't come soon enough
Charlotte Bellis al Jazeera